how do you convince people that you
actually practice
what you preach well if you're the us
office of the director of national
intelligence
apparently you do a bit of bad
photoshopping
at least if you go by the cover of the
odni's latest report
on diversity inclusion and equity
the intelligence community should
reflect the diverse makeup of america
and demonstrate that we are fostering an
environment where every professional can
succeed
promoting diversity equity and inclusion
is fundamental to our democratic values
and critical to meeting the isis mission
this takes work every single day
it didn't take long for people to notice
that the cover was
in fact a picture from shutterstock
literally titled
portrait of multicultural office staff
standing in lobby
what's more it was doctored to include a
woman in a wheelchair
and a blind guy with a guide dog problem
is these two were photoshopped in
so lazily that half the internet noticed
is the blind guy you photoshopped an
imagery analyst
lol you clowns photoshopped a blind guy
and dog in there
talk about virtue signaling because
nothing says
national intelligence like empty virtual
signaling with the shutterstock photo
while our enemies laugh at our woke
feckless elites
you might wonder why they didn't just
actually take a picture of their
actual staff if they're so diverse but
perhaps that's because the
odni just isn't as a diverse and
inclusive a place as
they would like you to think it is just
look beyond the front cover
inside the report itself there the
figures suggest that since 2019
women have seen no change in
representation whatsoever
while minorities gain just half a
percent and people with disabilities
even less than that it's almost as if
they're not really going
all in on hiring people based on skin
color and gender
perhaps it's shockingly merit and
qualifications that they're
actually after but then again even the
us intelligence community has to keep up
appearances
especially under this biden
administration
maybe that's why the u.s media has been
kind of silent on this story
after all can't have people thinking
that the current administration
isn't woke enough